what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a ton of Marvel news
to go over if you are wondering when we
are going to be getting that trailer for
the Marvels and whether or not the movie
is said to be good or not and if you're
wondering when that Loki season 2
trailer is coming and what the deal is
with Jonathan major since he got
arrested will be breaking both of these
down in this video today plus we have
news about another Marvel Studios delay
and we have some news about the end of
the Guardians of the Galaxy and James
Gunn has made a few recent comments
about whether or not Rocket Raccoon is
going to be dying in the movie and
whereas before we thought that he was
going to be just fine after these
comments were kind of wondering if he is
actually safe or not but we'll break it
all down in this video and if you're new
and you love Marvel and want to stay up
to date be sure to subscribe to the
channel and also comment on videos to
enter the giveaway we're giving away
things like a PS5 Xbox series X a Marvel
Legend items some DC items as well the
winner gets to pick and will pick a
winner at the end of each month now
first starting off with the Marvels you
may have heard that the trailer for the
Marvels is going to be coming Tuesday
tomorrow April 11th now as far as we
know so far there isn't a specific time
that this trailer is going to be
dropping at least we don't know however
Marvel Studios in the past has been
known to release trailers pretty early
in the morning if nothing is going on at
night like a sporting event or some
other big event and as far as we're
concerned right now there's nothing too
major happening on any of the channels
that Disney owns which leads me to
believe that we could be looking at one
of those early trailer drops although of
course Marvel Studios is not inclined to
keep any type of trailer release
schedule at all like I said they have
done this in the past and in the morning
trailer drops we can pretty much expect
it anytime between 7 A.M eastern time to
10 a.m eastern time but like I said they
can pretty much do it whenever they want
now on top of the this trailer release
date announcement that is coming from
Daniel rpk there has been some talk
about this movie there's even been talk
about the trailer according to Greece
Randolph she tweeted I heard this
trailer is excellent at least for fans
of the characters I'm excited and I
think a lot of fans are excited for this
movie more excited than the first
Captain Marvel film and there have been
test screenings for this film and based
off of what we've heard from some
insiders it wasn't doing so hot however
some people did say that it was actually
quite good so mixed reviews there
however we do know that the movie is
going through some major reshoots and we
know that right now Marvel Studios is
focusing on making better quality films
and TV shows so I think we are expecting
a pretty good movie here and apparently
the trailer for it is also supposed to
be pretty good so look out tomorrow if
we hear anything else about a specific
time we'll be sure to tweet about it or
put it on Instagram or do a community
post but then we have news about Loki
season 2 and it trailer for me this is
definitely one of my most anticipated
trailers and shows coming up and I think
it is for a lot of fans as well now as
far as the Loki season 2 trailer goes
Grace Randolph tweeted yesterday as for
Loki 2 the trailer is ready to go and we
should get it in the next few weeks now
secret invasion is about to come out and
after that Loki season 2 is coming out
as far as Disney Plus shows are
concerned so if the trailer is ready to
go and it's coming out in a few weeks
that means that we most likely aren't
getting a delay for Loki season 2 which
is great because Marvel Studios has been
going through a lot of delays right now
again always reminding it's for a good
cause to make everything better but
unfortunately things get delayed for
that now there is a second part to
Grace's tweet and she says I checked
with my sources and I hear no decision
has been made yet regarding Jonathan
majors and he is in the teaser trailer
for Loki season 2. now Insider Charles
Murphy also commented on this as well in
replying to a tweet that said I've seen
some reports Majors is out as King have
you heard anything in which Charles
responded I haven't heard a word about
that at this point now Jonathan majors
has not been charged as guilty yet and
his lawyer has released a bunch of
statements stating that he is actually
the victim in this and is not guilty
they have even released some text
messages as well now obviously when
you're a studio and you have an actor
that's supposed to lead a franchise
essentially as your main villain and
that actor gets arrested it's obviously
very concerning and you have to wonder
what you were going to do well I do
think Marvel Studios is going to wait
until the Court ruling until the court
rules on a decision on whether he is
guilty or not if he is not guilty I'm
sure Marvel Studios isn't really going
to do anything they're going to proceed
as planned however if they decide he is
guilty well that's when they're gonna
have to make a decision do they keep
Jonathan Majors as king the Conqueror or
do they recast him obviously you cannot
get rid of his character is the big bad
of the entire Multiverse Saga you can't
just say all right well we're done with
that character we need a big bad it has
to be king they've already set him up
they've already introduced the Council
of Kings so Kang is here no matter what
whether he's played by Jonathan Majors
or somebody else but right now Jonathan
Majors is innocent until proven guilty
and I think that's the stance that
Marvel Studios is taking they're pretty
much waiting to see what happens in
court and the next court date is May 8th
Which is less than a month away however
I have to assume that Marvel Studios is
going on as planned like Jonathan Majors
is going to be sticking around
especially if they are going to keep him
in the Loki season 2 trailer and that
thing is filmed it's done they have
filmed everything they need for that
show Jonathan Majors is a huge part of
that show and according to Grace
Randolph he is indeed in the trailer so
it does look like Marvel Studios is
simply going on as if he's going to be
innocent and nothing is going to change
with their King the Conqueror and he
does play an excellent Kang the
Conqueror so expect that trailer for
Loki season 2 in a few weeks now I'm
unfortunately I did mention we do have
another delay that's been revealed for a
Marvel Studios project this one won't
really affect the MCU but it is a highly
anticipated project and that is X-Men 97
the Animated Series both insiders can we
get some toast and Charles Murphy have
both stated that they've heard X-Men 97
is getting delayed until next year 2024.
now at this point in time we shouldn't
be too shocked when we hear about delays
coming from Marvel Studios in this point
after phase 4 and in the middle of Phase
5 in the MCU Marvel Studios has pretty
much decided not to rush things that
aren't ready and they are spacing out
their projects that way their visual
effects people aren't overworked and or
rushed to finish something so delays are
good delays mean Marvel Studios is
working harder to make it better and I
gotta say X-Men 97 this is a show that I
am super excited for and I think a lot
of fans are really excited for as well
so we want this to be done right so I'm
okay with this it does suck of course
all the delay suck but I would rather
them get delayed and be better now to
top it all off unfortunately Guardians 3
is the end of the Guardians team that we
know make no mistake the Guardians of
the Galaxy are going to continue to
exist in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's the really good news it just
won't be the same team now Chris Brad
has recently said in an interview that
he doesn't think that he's done playing
Star-Lord he said that even if his
character dies they could still bring
him back and that's 100 true we are in
the Multiverse Saga even if a character
dies the same actor could come back and
play a variant of that character which
is exactly why we're expecting to see so
many different cameos and Avengers
Secret Wars and why we're hoping that
actors such as Robert Downey Jr Scarlett
Johansson Chris Evan they're all
returning to play a variant of their
respected characters or maybe even
switch it up maybe Robert Downey Jr is a
Captain America variant in some Universe
with the Multiverse anything is possible
which makes it so exciting but going
back to Guardians of the Galaxy James
Gunn has has made some comments on
Instagram recently that make us believe
that maybe Rocket Raccoon isn't exactly
as safe as we thought in Guardians 3.
now I think everybody thinks that Drax
is for sure gonna die but a lot of
people including myself were thinking
that Rocket Raccoon is going to live
James gonna stated that he wanted to
finish Guardians 3 because he wanted to
finish the story of Rocket Raccoon and
he even said that he considers rocket to
be one of the main protagonists of the
entire franchise and Guardians 3 is
pretty much about Rocket Raccoon his
story about how the high evolutionary
created him and now essentially wants
him back now we know James Gunn is
pretty active online both on Instagram
and Twitter and he responded to a couple
of comments recently one of them stated
I hope rocket dies and James Gunn
replied using an emoji that's the white
eyes emoji now we're not gonna look too
into this because this could mean many
different things he could be stating
well you better watch out or he could be
simply replying to the fact that this
guy hates rocket however he did reply to
another comment that stated about to
piss me off when rocket dies if he does
they don't need to die send them off
world for a bit simple in which James
Gunn replied no one said he was going to
die but that's not how stories work and
that reminds us that James Gunn is a
Storyteller and this reminds us that
rocket actually isn't completely safe if
the story calls for him dying James
Gunn's gonna kill him if that's what the
story needs if that is the conclusion
that he comes to it's gonna happen and
James Gunn essentially reiterates here
that you can't just send him off world
and then just have him come back that's
not how his story for Guardians 3 Works
having said that though I still don't
think that Rocket Raccoon is going to
die I think rocket is going to get
somewhat of a happy ending and be one of
the survivors I do believe some
Guardians are going to die Drax included
maybe even Star-Lord maybe mantis which
is gonna break my heart although I think
the biggest one is going to be rocked it
if he dies I think a lot of of hearts
are going to be breaking and some big
tiers are definitely going to be
happening but hey let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you think Rocket Raccoon will
die if not who do you think is going to
bite the bullet in Guardians 3 and let
us know your thoughts on these upcoming
trailers the Marvel's Loki season 2. let
us know how excited you are for these to
finally come don't forget to like the
video please and of course subscribe if
you want to stay up to date on the
latest MCU news and enter our giveaway
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf